je déteste la quelle forme je veux aller
sur la côte est un endroit où il ya de
la culture voilà nous y sommes prudents
connecticut dans le new hampshire les
écrivains ligue dans le groupe
tu peux aller dans ce genre de non
content de toi de la saq du coin avec ta
vision du travail va à la fac du coin
puis en prison et retour à la fac et l'a
peut-être que tu apprendras te prendre
en main et à ne plus compter sur les
autres pour tout faire adaptable qui
bordent chez votre prénom
oui pourquoi tu l'écris avec des
guillemets je m'appelle comme ça c'est
le nom que je me suis donné à moi même
lady bird est toujours calée né du
mauvais côté des rails
j'ai toujours cru que c'était mieux
avant mais il ya vraiment une voie de
chemin de fer c'est qu'on fait ce que tu
fais très anarchiste pour prométhée le
magazine à sa place elle un grand coeur
ta mère elle est chaleureuse mais elle
me fait peur en totale chaleureuse et
faire part je crois que si ta mère
donc vous ne souhaitez postuler à aucune
université catholique
jamais je veux une fac gens réels mais
bon payet parce que je pourrais pas y
entrer
c'est sûr que vous n'avez aucune chance
elle me détestent maman on s'assied cité
fatick je suis pas fatigué tu traîne les
pieds
thual tomber sur les nerfs j'ai pas
trier je te signale watts et robes et
par où est elle te plaît c'est plutôt
vous avez toutes les deux une forte
personnalité
c'est quand le bon moment pour coucher
du coucher avec quelqu'un je suis prête
je voulais que ce soit spécial c'est
tout pourquoi tu vas voir tellement de
cette banale toute ta vie
[Musique]
nous avons peur de ne jamais pouvoir
échapper à nos potes parce qu'on te
donne s'est jamais assez et en faut
toujours normalement nous avons peur de
ce que l'avenir nous réserve
nous avons peur de ne pas être aimé pour
tourner autour de toi tu nous dis dans
cette crypte de ne pas être apprécié je
veux que je te dise un truc les salles
sa mère s'est même pas les bras et l'a
fait un mauvais choix 10 de pente non tu
es mauvais choix de ne pas réussi je
voudrais que tu présentes la meilleure
version possible de toi même
et si c'était ça le mieux que je puisse
faire
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien participer à une
olympiade de maths mais les maths ne
sont pas votre point fort n'est ce pas
ça ça reste à voir
[Musique]